друзі Всіх вітаю сьогодні одному
народному депутату вручена підозра ще
вдвох відбуваються обшуки чому такий
Бардак у Верховній Раді не треба вішати
ярлики
непевен вчить англійсько продовжиємо
наше парламентські хроніки де
розповідаємо про роботу Верховної Ради
України Ну не повинні депутати працювати
в таємному режимі цього тижня мав бути
повноцінний такий пленарний тиждень з
годиною запитань до уряду з
заслуховування міністерки у справах
ветеранів але слуги перепрацювалися і
все закінчилося у середу чому такий
Бардак у Верховній Раді з головних
законів які були проголосовані в
вівторок середу я би в першу чергу
відзначила ті які є обов'язковими
маяками для початку перемовин щодо
вступу України в ЄС і вимог МВФ для
надання нам фінансової допомоги без яких
Україна просто не виживе це в першу
чергу закон про набу ми з вами розуміємо
що ми зараз ухвалюємо один із
законопроектів маємо ухвалити який
рекомендувала Європейська комісія для
того щоби ми завершили принаймні
частково завершили виконання пункту який
стосується антикорупції в тих семи
умовах які ми отримали при на дані
кандидатського статусу який збільшує
кількість детективів з 700 до 1000
примітно Що в першому читанні цей
законопроект Верховна Рада проголосувала
в той час коли двом депутатам від слух І
правлячих от груп вручили підозри за те
що вони намагалися дати хабар Друзі Ну
сьогодні урожайний день давайте же
назвемо це І скажемо сьогодні одному
народному депутату вручена підозра ще
вдвох відбуваються обшуки Я не знаю чому
це все в один день можливо це нам
антикорупційні органи хочуть показати
свою ефективність так само в першому
читанні про голосовано законопроект про
посилення спроможності сап яким
виводиться спеціалізована антикорупційна
прокуратура зі структури Генеральної
прокуратури Це вже буде працювати як
окремий орган і там уточнюється
положення щодо конкурсу на керівника саб
все це дуже і дуже важливо звичайно
європейська Солідарність це підтримала
коли боротьба з корупцією відбувається
це добре І збільшувати автономію
спеціалізованої антикорупційної
прокуратури треба це символічний тиждень
ко коли ми згадуємо Героїв Небесної
Сотні Революції гідності і Верховна Рада
України прийняла кілька надзвичайно
важливих звернень до світу до України з
нагоди 10-ї річниці 10-х роковин
революції гідності чому переміг
Майдан тому що ми розуміли важливість
єдності тому що ми були стійкі і ми мали
непереборну волю до Незалежності і до
перемоги було дико слухати коли
представники вчорашньої Партії Регіонів
опзж рвали на собі тут вишиванки з
трибуни що вони за ЄС і НАТО я при тій
владі доказав що європейський вибір для
мене є визначальний так як і більшість
нашої депутатської групи Яка є сьогодні
в залі яка лишилася на території України
яка сьогодні сприяє перемозі України
позиція нашої політичної сили однозначна
ці партії мають бути не просто
заборонені в теорії А на практиці
понести відповідальність європейську
Солідарність сьогодні не випускають у
відрядження а представник опзж їде пієв
у Вашингтон в офіційній делегації
парламентській не треба вішати ярлики от
ми наполягаємо на тому аби представники
опзж були позбавлені права створювати
нові групи очолювати парламентські
комітети і входити в керівні органи і
взагалі не тільки в Верховній Раді
України а й в регіональних радах Бо я її
ментально і емоційно підтримую Дякую
ще один розрекламований законопроект -
це законопроект Про статус англійської
мови ініціатива глави держави була
озвучена і презентована широкому загалу
під час звернення президента України до
парламенту українського народу під час
святкування Дня Конституції України для
вступу України до ЄС і НАТО нам потрібно
мати цілі пласти такі категорії
державних чиновникі там інших службовців
які вільноі будуть володіти англійською
як мовою такого спілкування в країнах ЄС
і НАТО Чи потрібно нам краще вивчати і
більше застосовувати англійську мову
безперечно так чи потрібен для тоцього
спеціальний закон про англійську мову не
певен Але в цьому законопроекті були
закладені такі міни сповільненої дії
проти Української найбільше обурення в
суспільстві викликали його норми про
заборону показу в кінотеатрах
англомовних фільмів дубльованих
українською мовою це вбивало би сферу
дубляжу і креативних індустрій в Україні
і от саме представники європейської
солідарності наполягли на тому щоби ще
до першого читання на рівні комітету ці
чутливі норми були вилучені із
законопроекту звичайно не можна було б
навіть у першому читанні голосувати за
проект з такими небезпечними
антиконституційними і на жаль
русифікаційними нормами ми всі за
розширення знання англійської інших мов
спі вання країн-членів ЄС але Очевидно
це не може відбуватися за рахунок
державної української але до другого
читання варто вдосконалити цей проект
зокрема з цих міркувань чи не створимо
ми якийсь додатковий бар'єр потрапляння
на державну службу військовослужбовців
які зараз служать у війську і які
очевидно заслужили чи не найбільше
представляти Українську державу Далеко
не всі з них знають англійську мову
Верховна Рада України обрала нового
керівника фонду державного майна це вже
п'ятий керівник фонду держмайна при
зеленському попередники десь в бігах
зокрема Дмитра сеняченка звинувачують
багатомільярдних там якихось крадіжках
маніпуляціях новим керівником фонду став
Віталій Коваль він колишній очільник
Рівненської облдержадміністрації І от що
цікаво призначали керівника такої
важливої установи взагалі без
обговорення я не можу задати питання
кандидату Він дуже зайнятий І він не має
можливості відповісти на питання які
зараз виникають в чому він розбирається
в фонді держмайна який взагалі в нього
профіль як він може зараз продовжувати
ту реформу яку починав пан Рустем чи
буде все-таки перелік стратегічних
підприємств та інших об'єктів які не
підлягають або які заборонені до
приватизації Чи бачить він корупційні
складові в приватизації яка зараз широко
крикує країною ми не голосуємо за
кадрові призначення Влади не несемо за
це відповідальності але і протестував
проти такої форми призначення коли
навіть не можна зрозуміти така яка
програма Нового керівника Вітаю з
призначенням на відповідальну посаду
бажаю вам
успіхів Дякую Верховна Рада України
також прийняла звернення з нагоди 90-х
роковин голодомору Ми дякуємо всім
країнам які визнали голодомор геноцидом
українців Павло Everybody Thank you much
indeed for our
solidity
я вчіть англійську це коли-небудь вам
прийде до вподоби це дуже важливо
сьогодні відновлювати історичну
справедливість адже непокаране зло
повертається російськими ракетами
шахедами нині голодомор визнали
геноцидом 34 країни з них половина 17
зробили це після початку
повномасштабного вторнення в 22-му році
нинішні злочини Росії допомагають
зрозуміти її злочинні дії у минулому і
навпаки злочини минулого показують
коріння нинішньої геноцидної політики
російського імперіалізму Росія має бути
покарана і ми ще ще раз Дякуємо всім Хто
визнав голодомор геноцидом Росія не може
застосувати голод як зброю проти нас
тому що проти неї нині нерозрізнені
вияви протесту як це було в 1930 роки
проти неї нині потужні збройні сили
України Ми переможемо Тому що пам'ятаємо
про Голодомор пам'ятаємо ми сильні Слава
Україні нашу фракцію і весь парламент
дуже турбує ситуація на
україно-польському кордоні де
заблокованими знаходяться тисячі фур це
б'є по українському експортеру про нашій
дуже складній економіці і дії влади тут
ну виглядають якимись непрофесійними то
з трибуни генеральної асамблеї ООН щось
там заки дали нашим партнерам тепер
взагалі нечутно який діалог ведеться з
поляками для того щоб розблокувати цю
ситуацію і от На нинішньому пленарному
тижні Верховна Рада України прийняла
звернення до нового сенату і сейму
республіки Польща Ми сподіваємося що
коли вредині грудня зміниться уряд то
вони все зроблять для того щоб допомогти
нам розблокувати дороги і взагалі
розблокувати наше співробітництво
звичайно тут дуже важливо активізувати
парламентський діалог Ну але проблема
невипуску депутатів в першу чергу від
опозиції залишається кричущою і немає
такої зустрічі де б ми не піднімали ці
питання от Повірте не хочеться говорити
про негатив але усвідомлюємо що без
публічності без того що ми як єдина
насправді державницька опозиційна сила
яка сьогодні Ну точно не в опозиції до
України ми об'єднані навколо збройних
сил об'єднані навколо захисту країни але
ми маємо говорити владі про ці
неправильні кроки І речі які
відбуваються в країні які не наближають
нас до єсената колеги ми я би вас
просила присвятити окремі кілька годин
для того щоби прочитати всі 150 сторінок
висновку Європейської комісії по Україні
і зрозуміти що справа стосується не
тільки чотирьох підпунктів які зараз
Треба терміново виконувати для того щоб
відкрити перемовини про членство всі 150
сторінок говорять про ту роботу яку нам
треба буде далі виконувати І останнє
цього тижня голосувалося кілька
законопроектів які стосуються
українського експорту під благими
начебто намірами для того щоби
унормувати зловживання з продажем і
експортуванням українського зерна
насправді гайки закручується по суті до
ручного керування цією сферою ну Майте
хоча би якусь силу протистояти цьому
нездоровому підходу до аграріїв Ну
насправді тепер експорт перетворюється в
прямий терор аграрії в шоці від того ми
маємо дуже багато фактажу коли фермери
не можуть вивести своє збіжжя змушені
його тут за копійки здавати якимось
одноденкам фірмочкам які мають дозвіл
потім на цей експорт очевидно що є тут
багато зловживань А ви знаєте про
зерновий коридор морським шляхом всі
чорні експортери заплатили 5% від
оціночної вартості партії і попали Таким
чином на корабель куди заплатили в
карман декому хто розслідує ці випадки
ТСК бажаю ТСК все ж таки знайти тих
крадіїв які замість державного бюджету
замість збройних сил України забрали 5%
від 300 компаній чорних експортерів
зерна а от з хорошого Я дуже пишаюся
позицією нашої колеги Ніни юженівної яка
змогла на рівні комітету пролонгувати
важливу поправку в законодавстві щодо
пільги продовження її на один рік на 24й
рік на ввезення комплектуючих
для вироблення безпілотників
тепловізорів і навезення самого цього
дуже чутливого
е імпорту для України не дивіться будь
ласка тільки в одну сторону Враховуйте
думку всіх друзі Ми продовжимо
інформувати про роботу парламенту тому
підписуйтеся на наш YouTube канал
коментуйте лайкайте все буде Україну